o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
e quando nasci um anjo esbelto desses
que tocam trombeta anunciou vai carregar
Bandeira calma muito pesado precisar
para a mulher essa espécie ainda
envergonhada aceito os subterfúgios que
me cabem sem precisar mentir não sou tão
feia que não possa casar acho o Rio de
Janeiro uma beleza e ora sim ora não
creio em parto sem dor mas o que sinto
escrevo culpa assina inauguro linhagens
fundo reinos dor não é na minha tristeza
não tem Pedigree já minha vontade de
alegria
o suais vai de mil fogo
e vai ser coxo na vida e maldição pra
homem mulher Anderson bravo eu sou
e esse poema é da nossa Saudosa a
escritora Adélia Prado uma mulher
nascida em 1935 e que lá e da década de
70 resolveu inaugurar sua obra literária
com o livro bagagem que trás toda a sua
a sua história de vida lá no interior de
Minas onde onde nasceu
e essa mulher como muitas outras
nascidas na década de 30 40 50 70 foram
nascidas e criadas numa sociedade
patriarcal então inaugura essa fala
agora para você que está me ouvindo
homem e mulher não importa Quais as suas
crenças mas eu inaugura essa fala com
essa reflexão qual é o papel da mulher
hoje ainda hoje no século 21 a mulher
mãe a mulher menina a mulher mulher a
mulher que luta a mulher profissional
uma sociedade ainda para patriarcal
e eu eu me espelho nessas mulheres e
muitas outras mas temos várias mulheres
que nós podemos nos inspirar por exemplo
nossas avós a nossas mães uma tia uma
irmã mais velha com a Dona Maria aquela
senhora que trabalha na de merendeira na
escola não importa a função a qual essa
mulher ela está na sociedade que importa
é que nós mulheres somos nós mulheres eu
fico imaginando uma menina quando nós
nascemos nós nascemos nessa sociedade e
falamos desse patriarcado todo Eu sempre
gosto de refletir sobre alguns pontos eu
eu posso aqui citar a minha experiência
né Assim como várias que Talvez possa
servir de inspiração para você que tá aí
nesse estilo por exemplo nós meninas
quando nascemos nós estão cheias dos
sonhos né quando criança
é mas sonhamos isso é modelo ser atriz
Há muitas coisas sonho em casar e ter
uma família os sonhos vão de encontro às
nossas expectativas futuras e também eu
eu creio que os sonhos ele também está
ligado ao cerne onde vivemos a nossa
família né nossa cultura é também é
cultural nosso sono o que as nossas mães
elas transferem para nós muitas vezes né
e eu como mãe possa dizer isso
e quando eu era criança quando era
menina eu vivia sonhando e eu fui criada
no lá no largo cinco irmãs mais um irmão
memória o Caçula e quando eu lembro
dessa se para tirar casa toda lembra o
meu pai ele ficava esperando o tempo
todo aquela Aquele filho que nunca vinha
na minha mãe tá de cinco filhas para
depois vir o menino da casa
e eu lembro quando poderei nasceu eu
quer dizer eu não lembro porque eu tinha
um ano e pouco mas falado né nunca nós
vivemos assim e o meu pai falava o tempo
todo né agora nós temos um machão em
casa nessa figura do macho né E quando
nós brincar vamos ver meu irmão mas
brincávamos de bola de boneca de várias
coisas e quando brincava de bola com e
jogava futebol brincava de carrinho de
rolimã não não havia nenhuma recusa por
parte do meu pai ele respeitava isso me
mas quando meu irmão brincava de boneca
comigo com as minhas irmãs Eu lembro que
o meu pai meio que não gostava porque
ele tinha que ter aquela figura de
marcha ou macho
bom então isso ainda hoje eu vejo que
isso é muito Evidente ainda é muito
forte ainda nossa sociedade porque nós
mulheres ainda estamos numa luta
constante de conseguir nosso espaço na
sociedade Adélia Prado quando eu falei
dela eu quis iniciar sua fala com ela eu
poder iniciar com várias outras né
pessoas escritores maravilhosa para ver
se eles teto que nasceu na década de 20
inaugura em 1946 o livro perto do
Coração Selvagem que é uma obra
extremamente autobiográfica que ela se
coloca como mulher na sociedade e
lutando por esse por esse patriarcado né
por tudo isso que ela que ela passou
para mim durante tantas outras que a
gente pode acertar inclusive nossas
mulheres nada nossa família mas como
escolher a melhor pago eu pensei assim
que quando ela lançou esse poema se
livro bagagem foi a década de 70 né
então
o que o que o feminismo no Brasil ele
teve uma consolidação digamos assim ele
iniciou no século 18 né alguns
movimentos de algumas feministas
escritoras e vários artistas mas foi na
década de 70 no Brasil especificamente
que o feminismo e ele tomou um corpo
maior né junto a várias outras vários
outros acontecimentos que a década de 70
três e é a minha década de nascimento né
então eu eu vi nesse meio né nesse meio
todo uma menina cheia de sonhos e de
repente quando nós chegamos na
adolescência né O que é adolescência O
que é ser meninas ser adolescente sem
molhar nós chegamos na adolescência
sempre com as dúvidas né a
pré-adolescência que muitas vezes muito
precocemente acontece principalmente nós
mulheres
é mas chegamos sem dúvidas né os
hormônios estão à Flor da Pele aí ela
falar em pele na pele começa aparecer as
espinhas e os Cravos as acnes o nosso
corpo começa numa transformação tremenda
né e começa a surgir a estereótipos né O
que é mais bonito que tá na moda na
minha época de adolescente na década de
80 Não isso não era tão forte ainda
tínhamos é claro os padrões usos os
modelos né Mas isso não era tão forte
quanto hoje eu fico imaginando hoje o
advento das redes sociais e isso é muito
Evidente né que ela disputa todos os
dias para o cabelo assim por uma pele
perfeita um corpo padrão e isso às vezes
faz com que nós mulheres nos sentimos
deprimidos digamos assim o sentimos a
gente muitas mulheres às vezes não se
acha que não se encaixam na sociedade
e não manter um padrão pré-determinado
né pela cultura pela pelo consumismo e
pelas redes sociais também
e eu lembro que na minha adolescência o
adorava ser a Cyndi Lauper naquela época
década de 80 né E só que a minha
adolescência ela foi ela foi muito curta
eu eu casei muito cedo o que que
aconteceu né eu tinha 14 anos eu fiz
trabalha fora eu quero trabalhar e
estudar à noite isso para mim era um
motivo de sair de casa eu era muito
preso meu pai super cuidava Neo a caçula
das mulheres aquela questão do cuidado e
eu tinha essa vontade que eu quero
trabalhar durante o dia estudar à noite
extra minha opção porque para sair de
casa principalmente para ter um motivo
né
e ainda pai chegou falou não tu vai
escolher outro trabalho que estuda eu
escolhi trabalhar eu comecei a trabalhar
com 14 anos infelizmente abandonei 8ª
série na época e fui trabalhar só que lá
com 16 anos me deu à vontade do retorno
às aulas Que eu sempre gostei muito de
leitura estudar e eu sentia necessidade
disso eu já tinha um namoradinho
terminei com ele só que na sequência
conheci o outro bem mais velho que eu e
eu vi esse outro uma válvula de escape
para sair de casa enfim Resumindo casei
aos 17 anos
e com 18 anos foi mãe
E aí de repente vem a maternidade né tão
jovem e já estava estudando inclusive
voltei os estudos não parei aí me veio
aquela frase na mente uma frase que eu
sempre eu via em homenagem as escolas em
cartões do Dia das Mães né Ser mãe é
padecer no paraíso' essa frase ela veio
sobre mim como choque eu comecei a
refletir sobre essa frase até hoje eu
faço reflexões eu converso com as Minhas
alunas com a minha filha sobre essa
frase o que são dois extremos né para
isso aquela coisa dela mas é aquela
coisa maravilhosa Só que os verbos para
descer significa sofrer
e eu não aceitava esse fato Ser mãe é
sofrendo Paraíso então é sofrer mas
estado para isso
E aí me veio novamente aquela ideia né
aquele pensamento do patriarcado que o
peso que nós mulheres temos em relação a
maternidade a família a sociedade e é
isso é essa reflexão que eu quero trazer
para você hoje mulher e homem também que
está aqui me assistindo o ruim isso
ainda hoje né prevalece essa esse peso
de nós mulheres nós somos pronta Adélia
Prado falou mulher e desdobrável eu sou
e realmente nós somos desdobráveis né
porque nós conseguimos fazer várias
tarefas ao mesmo tempo ser maravilhoso
nós temos essa capacidade então vez é
maravilhoso só que talvez a sociedade
cobre muito de nós porque é porque você
consegue você vai nós não temos que ter
essa também essa responsabilidade de
tudo
a semana maravilhoso eu digo que eu amo
maternidade e também sou favorável a
Cláudia aquelas mulheres que não querem
a maternidade nós temos que respeitar
isso que não é toda mulher que aceita
maternidade é um respeito que temos de
ter né é importante mas o que eu quero
dizer é que nós mulheres
e na sociedade patriarcal que ainda
vivemos estamos na luta ainda e temos
sim que buscar os nossos ideais nosso
lugar e temos que sobretudo se
respeitadas respeitadas na sociedade o
trabalho em casa e quero convidar você
mulher você menina mulher a refletir
sobre esse poema e sobre a vida né que
nós essa início que ela fala ele vai
carregar a bandeira cargo muito pesado
pra mulher
e isso traz toda essa carga de
patriarcado que lá naquela época dela é
parado ela foi criada para ser mãe para
casar né hoje em dia mudou um pouco mas
ainda existe muitas famílias que cobram
isso das mulheres mas que nós temos que
pensar que nós temos uma função muito
além de ser apenas né apenas essa mulher
Nós não somos sexo frágil nós somos
fortes nós somos desdobráveis Então essa
reflexão que eu deixo para vocês e que
isso possa Florescer algo da luta da
luta que nós temos ainda hoje na
sociedade a qual Vivemos em